So now when you're up and running with conference
central you have a pretty good idea of how to
write and deploy app engine applications. In the last lesson
we also covered usage management and we added it to
conference central so only authenticated users can access the application.
When you write applications you very often need to store
data. And as you know, there are a number of
ways you can do this. App Engine is no exception.
It can work with a number of different storage technologies.
But there is one that is particularly important, it's called Datastore.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This is the Big Table restaurant here at Google. You may have heard of Big
Table. It's a technology Google created and
published a famous paper about in 2006. Big
Table allows unlimited amount of data to
be stored and searched effectively. And many of
the huge services being run here at Google
chose Big Table to store data. You know
what? App Engine Datastore also uses Big Table. That means
that your applications ge the same massive scale. Isn't that great?
Hm, but I'm starting to feel a little bit hungry. Hey! I think I'll go in,
and get a big bite in the Big Table restaurant! See you in class! [NOISE]